for the first time on this program
pleased to have the man in place Richard
splett
on that program Sam Richardson good to
see you see you of course now the radio
audience cannot see so we need to paint
the word picture yes you hobbled your
way into this chair using a crutch which
is only right crutch I made my way very
bravely and gallantly to the seat that
I'm sitting in now yes because they have
a torn meniscus and your left knee and
my left knee your your plane hurt today
I'm playing hurt but I'm brave so you
know I thought I'd just go for it
I think it's very brave did you how did
you hurt your left knee Sam I'm saying I
was working out in the gym and I was
doing barbell squats hit a deep squat
and I heard a pop in my knee oh no way
and I was like if I did a couple more
and I was like this is probably a
problem so I stopped and then like I was
fine all day it was like Friday and
Saturday I was like mmm I should
probably go to intense to Urgent Care so
into urgent care they're like ooh
this might be an LCL might be something
so I wouldn't get an MRI got the MRI
results like a couple days ago and
they're like oh it's a torn meniscus oh
so when do you go under the knife when
do we go I don't know I talked to a
specialist tomorrow I just do it myself
[Laughter]
surgery is it's it's an unknown art it's
growing rapidly growing rapidly you know
well so this is a true story right I
mean yes it's not like you know I was
slipping in the shower like no this good
for you how how many pounds were you I
think one ton like 160 pounds okay like
you know another person okay smaller
than you know our sound engineer our
audio executive Mike Dell 2fo who's kind
of around the corner from those cameras
from you
he says he would want he could plank to
25 and we're like that's impressive
right I mean you paint you know that's
that's two plates of 25 it's but it's
too late 45 when he says yes very clever
word usage that's just the way he says
these things oh yeah so this is look
lying what I'm saying maybe this is
something that could be portable from
your first ever appearance on this show
yes you utilize that phraseology when
you're asked the question of how much
weight were you in fact squatting when
you hurt your knee yeah I'll say like
what 275 there you go no no don't don't
say five so you say 275 no no Joe just
say to you were squatting 275 oh yeah
yeah I was wide in 275 and then heard
that pop was a shame everybody like whoa
and then I just move on past it like
real quick right as a matter of fact if
you don't mind let's just play it out if
I see okay so Sam you hurt your knee how
did you hurt your name doing barbell
yeah barbell squad like I squat in 275
tell the truth Sam Richardson how did
you hurt your left knee I was doing a
barbell squat 275 275 yeah that's it but
it's so easy for you he can't even do
yeah he's an actor exactly so that means
everything I say on camera I'm telling
the truth in Richardson here on the
richezza show you're from the great
state of Michigan I am
Detroit City great state of Michigan so
growing up your team's word be
we're the Lions of the Kushans Tigers
now when I was at the University of
Michigan the bad boys were killing it
yeah and I hated them every fiber of my
being
yeah and and that with the exception of
Joe Dumars he was unhittable yes Joe
Dumars fruit cooler you he was just
somebody I could not find the hate for
even when he was torching the Knicks
which is my team from New York yeah what
was it like being grown up much with the
bad boys doing oh I dare say I was very
young but I've got the I had a a Isiah
Thomas poster on my wall of Lies the a
Thomas [ __ ] my dad I remember there
was a it was 1990 now six years old okay
and young that was young okay I'm old
you're young okay I was 36 years old
thirty-six my dad would let me watch the
game and I didn't still remember I was
like this is a big event but uh bad boys
documentary oh yeah so they yeah I mean
lamb beer and my Bjorn
Horn Rodman Rodman before he was with
the Bulls wrong and Robin the distance
yep I know they were they were real and
the Red Wings were great when I was
there too and the Tigers were just to
beat you know again I'm dating myself
and you went to Wayne State went Wayne
State University now I remember
at the time when I was at school the
school's nickname were the Tarte ours
target is that changed or as uh the
Tartars the Tartars isn't what they were
Wayne State Warriors now changed it we
always wondered that's really odd that
they would may have they're like just
like after the sauce Astrea sauce
strange but they've changed it now
a lot of fish fantastic I love it hey
man I love you on this show I'm
fantastic on it what in the world is it
like being in a room when you get a
script for veep and everybody around you
is seeing it for the first time well
it's a lot really great because we get
the scripts in the table read so we're
sitting there for the table read for the
episode like maybe about a few days or a
week before we start shooting in her
and like we're reading it in time
sometimes you get a little bit of a
chance like read before you do the read
but we're all like laughing fully
because these scripts are just so funny
you know and like we're also like season
7 so we're all very familiar with our
characters and like everybody at the
table read is so funny you you know get
Julia you got Tim Simon's yet Tony Hale
get Matt Walsh like all these people who
are just so funny and like we're like a
family so that we get to read these
scripts and it's just really a good time
yeah it's gotta be it's gotta have a
Gary Cole as well we had a Kevin yeah we
had Kevin Dunn on the show just about a
month ago
oh yeah it is so funny he really is he's
so damn funny so how did what brought
you out to Los Angeles I was working at
the second city in Chicago of doing
sketch comedy who was with you on the
stage my friend my best friend Tim
Robinson and I were on the main stage
together right there's Katie rich like
Holly Lorentz order Blackman what a what
a place to to cut your teeth yeah city
in Detroit first okay then I got hired
to do a cruise ship for second city so
living a cruise ship for a year what
doing comedy shows this is second city
cruise ship yeah we were on Norwegian
cruise lines right and like at that time
I would work like five hours a week I
would just kind of go on the ship all
right would live on the ship but we do
like an hour-long show two hour-long
shows the beginning of the week two
hour-long shows the rest at the end of
the week
the rest of time I was just like living
on a cruise ship just fully trying to
keep myself alive drink packaged drink
that no drink that's how they get you
more money than ever made before I was
like yeah I just couldn't drink out
these bars like a drink out in Barbados
all the time and then like for my first
contract I was like how did I not save
any money like I was on vacation for
five months you worked to cruise
essentially yeah yep and a comedy cruise
on a comedy cruise by the way I've never
been on a cruise anytime I
think about going on a cruise I just get
I get some sort of I'm not
claustrophobic or anything like that who
you are kind of trapped but I would I
would feel like uh if I was on a comedy
cruise though that's a different story
well we were the whole crews was in
comedy but we were like we were at you
were like one of the shows you know who
else was at doing the entertaining like
there was a dancing there was like a
dance show okay
there's like one show called sea legs
which I would see all the time there was
a magician trust me it's good sea legs
sea legs is it true that you were in an
unaired mary j blige Burger King
commercial is that a factor or not that
is that is a half fact okay it was us it
was a sketch that we did for Second City
where I was like the idea was it was a
commercial that marriage Lodge was doing
okay so there was no such thing as a
real commercial it wasn't a real so what
was this skit it was that mary j blige
this was like after she can't remember
what the cat is a long time ago but like
but for nine the funk was playing mary j
blige
and like she was just up there singing
about Burger King sandwiches to the
point where we almost believed that's
why we okay let's do start bench cut
with Sam Richardson here on the Rich
Eisen show
it's his first foray here we'll start
bench cut with Sam here I think I know
the first answer to this one so you have
to start one bench one and cut one okay
all right so it's sort of you know the
old game yeah your favorite piston from
the bad-boy era Isiah Mahorn or Vinny
the microwave Johnson oh man imagine if
they were if the 3-point line game was
the way it was now at Vinnie Johnson
coming off the bench the microwave who
would you we give to start one bench one
and cut one
I know Rick Mahorn personally as my
friend what do you mean he did my show
Detroiters on Comedy Central and he came
and he played himself on the show I
missed that episode yeah episode 10 of
season 1 well you definitely remember
that I should reach out to Rick yourself
we reached out to him and like we talked
to him the phone he was like kind of
like a Big Momma's House kind of thing
he was doing like a play and they kept
putting on the black I'm gonna kill you
guys and then he like wrapped our cars
around and like a cellophane tape okay
and then cut vide Johnson yeah oh okay I
know it happens that's that's the
vagaries of this game Sam you're
learning on the fly a few more here
favorite piston from the Larry Brown
championship era Rip Hamilton Ben
Wallace Rasheed Wallace start bench cut
okay I'm gonna start Rasheed Wallace
mm-hmm man I'll bench Rip Hamilton I
know it's tough to do these are hardly
by the way great kudos to our Los
Angeles broadcasting Center crew to
choose of all the photographs of Rip
Hamilton that famous see-through mass
yes that he wore the best musician from
Detroit mmm Stevie Wonder Smokey
Robinson start Ben Chicago ahead and get
me Stevie Wonder to start I'm gonna
bench Smokey and then I'm gonna cut him
in him sorry yeah see you see him out
the out the gate Stevie Wonder is the
first Motown artist written and the
greatest very good well I sure start
bench cut right here
hey man also is it true you played Jim
Brown and drunk history I did the
Cleveland summit and so for for drunk
history like the
youth of the person's voice who's like
doing the story person sells drunk story
and they said like memorize it and I
just like listen to it a lot and so then
you're there in the garb and I was just
sitting there and like you just like you
heard Jim's voice in your head is a
person telling stories even my ass Jim
Brown I'm not saying I see the words
drunk lady telling the story Joe and
that's how you got Jim Brown Desalle
Gajan brown down at the Cleveland sound
Cleveland summit yeah fantastic
hey Sam I'm a big fan of yours man I
really appreciate you coming in thank
you so much Sam Richardson on Twitter at
the Sam Richardson on instagram check
out the final season of veep it is as
funny as it has ever been
10:30 p.m. Eastern Time on HBO and it'll
get a little game of Thrones bump coming
up as well all right are you Game of
Thrones fan I am okay do you have any
theories on your ending and Sam what do
you got for me um well I think bran
stark is gonna control in those dragons
that's what you think I think so
for sure okay um I think we're gonna
lose a stark like a mainland I think
because nobody thinks we're gonna lose
that stark I think we're gonna lose big
Stark well I mean there's not many of
them left but I would say that would Ari
is gonna go because we've been following
this like every time the Starks are like
here we go so she's like she's been the
longest one looking for justice yeah
there's no way she's gonna live well in
the way on that front if we go down a
list wormhole a little bit here I know
we're watching my wife and I will
rewatch in season one oh yeah and all
the articles that I've read about it
we've read about is that season one is
gonna be they're gonna tie the seasons
together this last one in season one
together and the spoiler alert decisions
that Ned Stark makes based on principle
based on honor based on the right thing
to do
yeah and how he winds up because he
follows all that as opposed to what you
should do in the game of Thrones which
is be the meaning the gamut of all time
that
maybe that's what does Aria into see
where I'm going for trying to pack your
place and I think I think we're both
right I just have a concerned that it
ends with the White Walkers just wipe
them all out and we'll just be looking
at each other like just do for 18 years
I know but then like then you'll find
out that there's like enter politics
within the White Walkers people that
would Sam Richardson again on veep check
it out 10:30 p.m. Eastern Time every
Sunday on HBO we are back with 84 for
204 rich your phone calls setting up our
number-3 with terry rozier of the
celtics and graham rahal our good buddy
from Honda racing back here in the
studio for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app